we are so glad that you are back yes um
you've been with us since the beginning
as i've said um please take it away and
tell our next story zayn okay next up
okay so we've got to look to our elders
for that wise advice on how to live a
good life and the new york post reports
that a british great grandmother named
lily buhlen just turned 102 years old
and she says that her secret is tequila
yes she goes
yes
ma'am
yes
yes
so she celebrated with shots this year
and she says that tequila has helped her
love her life and she also credits pizza
who doesn't love her right i love this
woman i always say you know happy hour
equals happy life and it's not about
getting drunk but it's about like having
fun you know and to think that like
that's the secret is just loosen up a
little bit have a slice of pizza girl
sign me up also i get really like
sometimes i'll watch like interviews
with j.lo who i'm obsessed with yes i've
been begging her please please come
grace us with your presents on the show
but i want to say to you i'm i'm afraid
sometimes like she i can tell she drinks
water and works out and like it has that
diligent lifestyle and i'm like oh my
god i am like a dumpster fire next to
this one
i am just like
you know there's there's the people who
like live the healthiest cleanest lives
and then they get hit by a bus you know
and then there's the people who are like
i've been smoking for 109 years old and
i'm still here you know so
i think the i think the key is what you
said ross it's joy however you get it
how do you find it it's yeah it's it's
laughter and joy is what keeps you alive
i agree i agree
well what about this story
we've got a new wedding trend you might
not have heard of yet it's called well
you know monogamy right well what's the
solo version right you know what's the
solo version of monogamy they call it
sologomy which means a wedding for one
insider reports more brides are choosing
to go it alone and they're getting
married to themselves some women are
doing it with just a wedding ring others
are adding the dress a full guest list
throwing in a ceremony with a reception
and appetizers solagamus say it's an act
of commitment to yourself to loving
yourself and having
more self-compassion i saw drew sipping
her tea over there thoughts
i mean i i love i'm single for six years
i love
like my solo life
but i don't really get the monogamy with
the marriage and sologamy like it sounds
like sausage or yeah
like no no no no it's too much yeah it's
too much
let's just yeah it's just first of all
now because you love yourself i have to
spend 300 on a bridesmaid dress
no
but this this is what happened i knew it
was going to get out of hand the moment
we started celebrating birthdays for
months i was like we're going to start
marrying ourselves yeah
and how does it even work are you like i
do oh i do too oh this is great
or like do you wear a wedding ring if
someone like wants to date you you're
like i'm taken by with
you know kind of like um you know
there's these like grand weddings
there's like a scale of what people can
afford so it's like yeah you can have
this like grand cute wedding but then
what about the person that like doesn't
have much do they just go down to like
the justice of the piece like it's just
me
[Laughter]
you know that all said sometimes i give
myself the test in my own brain of like
someone who was really empowered by this
like i had never thought of a divorce
registry until we talked about it on the
show because it was the news story and i
thought oh god all the people that like
lose so much stuff and their friends
want to help but they don't know how and
this could be a whole new movement
you know what to each their own if
people want to do this and you know
hey love yourself well now how about
this if you want to take care of
yourself go on vacation don't marry
yourself girl what are you doing
you know i think like the less we judge
each other the better that's all i'm
gonna say do what you do you or i mean
[Music]
you